I want you to publish this you finally
gonna let me publish one of your poems
but you can't print my name why not
because my father doesn't approve of
women publishing
[Music]
what's so incredible about playing a
person that existed lifetimes ago is her
story and her voice is so relatable in
what she faces everyday as a young woman
do not approve of a woman seeking a
literary reputation women in a certain
sense were property you will tender your
duties as your mother does and we're
trying to find the uncanny resonances
between the 1850s and today in this
house
what matters is what your father wants
we're not doing a biopic of Emily
Dickinson in any kind of straightforward
sense we are doing our own poetic
interpretation of Emily Dickinson to
create a modern and feminist retelling
of her life they're gonna make a good
housewife one day and the lady consume
it's high time for you to get a husband
emily has this need for intellectual
stimulation and to be seen as the equal
of men why won't you marry me I'm not
gonna marry anyone she believed in
herself she was a practical woman who
was completely aware of her gifts why
can't I go to the college look an
education prepares one for a career and
the career of a woman is in the home
even though she was told that her work
will never see the light of day that
never stopped her she kept going it's
not up to my father to decide my fate
but it's not up to you knowing that her
way with words have had an impact on so
many people around the world
incredibly inspirational and it's been
wonderful to bring that to life
you
you